come with me to dive in Cozumel Mexico
this is going to be so much fun but
first we have to get there I always pack
too much luggage but the day that we
were leaving was the day of the
hurricane in Los Angeles it was a little
bit cloudy but all things considered we
got there with no problems at all I flew
JetBlue direct from LAX to Cancun and
once we landed of course we gotta wait
for our bags packing for trips like this
is always a struggle because you have to
bring so much gear not only do you need
to bring all of your dive gear but I
have so much camera gear we made it to
the ferry to make our way to Cozumel and
the ferry was actually quite nice I was
starving because I hadn't eaten since
breakfast so we had a snack and within
no time we were back on the other side
waiting for our bags and here's
everything this is all of all of the
things such so many things I'm just glad
that we made it all in one piece I am
tired and I'm hungry and can't wait to
get to the hotel we took a taxi to the
fiesta Americana where we were greeted
with his incredible welcome drink it was
amazing and then when I get to my room
there's these tiny little chocolates and
one was in the shape of a scuba diver
these just look so good and in contrast
I got to dinner and there was some
guacamole with worms in it I know this
is a thing but I didn't try it but
everyone else at dinner said it was
pretty delicious I had these delicious
fried cheese taco thingies and they were
amazing and then I got back to my room
and I had to prep for the next day of
diving I'm still very new at scuba
diving and I have a few masks to try out
so I have to prep them so that they
won't fog the next day I love that
Oceanic has so many pink accessories so
obviously I have to have pink everything
now that everything's ready I went to
bed and in the morning this was the most
incredible view I was greeted by a
triple rainbow all the way across the
sky oh I just couldn't believe it what a
sight so I've got all of my gear packed
and it's time to head down to breakfast
everything is so heavy it just feels
like I'm gonna fall over with all of the
stuff breakfast was tasty got a carb
load and then we also have to load in
all of the gear we took a taxi to appear
where we'd be catching a boat everything
here is so beautiful the water is so
clear I just could not wait to dive in
for the first time now that I've really
gotten into diving having my own gear
has been so awesome so huge thank you to
Oceana for hooking me up with all of
these goodies when I first started it
was great to have rental gear just to
get familiar but now learning on my own
gear has made it so much easier this is
Devin and his awesome red camera
underwater setup I can't wait to show
you guys the video that we were filming
although spoiler alert a lot of the
videos that you're gonna see are
actually coming right from my iPhone
Oceanic is coming out with a dive
housing and I can't wait to show you the
full review video we did a few Dives and
then it was time for lunch after being
under the water for so long you
definitely get hungry so time to eat we
all did one more dive after that and of
course it was so much fun also along
with me on this dive was Melody she is
super talented you can check her out on
Instagram watermelody we packed up all
of our gear headed back to Shore and
then of course went to the hotel for
dinner the food was so good I love
eating I just I really love food and
after that I went to bed and prepared
for another two days of diving I had so
much fun thank you guys for coming along
with me on this fun trip can't wait to
share the full video with you